today I'm going to do the second in my
series of three videos on what I call
the tripod the three length tripod sorry
the three legs that you have to stand on
to succeed in language learning the
three T's whatever you want to call them
the trilogy the trip triptych whatever
there's three the first one was your
attitude so I did a video on the kind of
attitude you need to have and the kind
of attitude you should avoid I noticed
that my microphone wasn't very you know
cleverly placed here hopefully the sound
improve now we're gonna talk about time
there are three things that you need to
succeed in language learning as I said
attitude time and the ability to notice
time is key it takes a long time to
learn a language there may be the odd
genius or autistic person who can do it
in ten days three months whatever but
for most people it takes a long time
Luka who is one of along with you know
Richard simcha a few others one of those
really outstanding multilingual people
that you can find on on YouTube he says
it takes him two years to learn a
language so if it takes look at two
years it's it takes a long time
obviously this depends I it's gonna take
him two years perhaps to learn Japanese
I'm sure that going from Latin the
Spanish didn't take them anything like
two years time is the major resource
that you have to invest in language
learning so you want to make sure that
your use of time is as effective and as
enjoyable as possible so it's very
important you got to spend a lot of time
but you want to do it in ways that are
effective and enjoyable and ultimately
it's you the learner that has to decide
how you want to spend that time
essentially to learn a language you have
to listen you have to read you have to
speak you have you might want to write I
think writing is a good thing to do but
it's more difficult to do very
and you have to review all the nuts and
bolts you review sometimes grammar rules
you review words and that sort of that
the studying of the nuts and bolts so
you have to decide where do you like to
spend your time do you like you to spend
your time reviewing flashcards do you
like to spend your time reviewing
grammar rules do you like to spend your
time reading listening writing speaking
you decide how to spend the time the key
thing is to spend time with the language
because when you're spending time with
the language that gives your brain a
chance to get used to this new language
and to develop the neural networks the
connections amongst you know between
neurons that's going to enable you to
speak the language comfortably now in my
own case as you may know if you follow
my videos I like to listen and read for
the first little while and eventually
then start to speak and so I'm not too
fussed about the grammar rules in the
early stages I mean I just today for
example I was listening to my FM IV and
they were talking about the recent you
know disturbances in Warsaw so I'm
getting a Russian perspective on the
euro cup and and the problems you know
the disturbances between fans there the
Russian and polish fans and I'm
listening to it I understand it all but
when I speak I make mistakes I still
make mistakes with my cases it doesn't
really bother me I know that I can get
in there later on when it matters and I
can work on improving them but I find it
enjoyable I'm interacting with the
language I've spent a lot of time
listening and reading and now if I look
at my check for example which I've been
at now for about eight or nine months
just today I was you know reading
various news articles interviews and
also chapters from the good soldiers
fake unly where I have all the you know
words are already saved in yellow and as
I'm reading I'm listening to it a
necessity I can understand everything I
can understand everything there's the
odd word that I miss but I'm listening
to it I understand it obviously if I
listen without reading I have
or trouble but I feel a great sign of
satisfaction so I'm doing things that I
enjoy doing I'm interacting with a
language and yet in Czech I have some of
the basic things you know the this that
in masculine feminine in different cases
I I have a clue and it doesn't bother me
because I know that at a later stage I
can go in there and I will focus on
getting those right but in the meantime
I'm getting tremendous enjoyment out of
doing the things that I like to do which
is listen and read and access radio
books I would understand a movie and so
for this one but other people may be
motivated differently so the thing is to
do the thing spend time on the things
that you enjoy doing in my own view
going to a school attending a class is
relatively low efficiency because you're
unless you're one-on-one with the
teacher but if there is a class with 10
or 15 or 20 people you're really not
interacting so closely with the language
you're not listening to it all the time
you're not reading it all the time
you're listening to the fellow you know
your fellow students it's not something
that I like to do but it's a social
event and some people require it from
the point of view of discipline for
language learning so if that's what you
like to do do it I just think that
that's that even if you go to class what
really matters is the time you spend
with the language away from class it's
not the time in class it's the time you
spend with the language away from class
so the great thing about listening as an
activity is that you can create time you
can do it I'm doing the dishes I'm doing
it I'm sitting in the car I'm doing it
so that you know that's a very flexible
way or getting in the amount of time
that you need people always ask how much
time do you mean well it depends on
circumstances I think less than an hour
a day you're not gonna make much
progress but I think enough 45 minutes
to an hour a day I think is a is a very
acceptable amount of time to spend and
you can expect to make good progress in
an hour a day I think the value with my
check now I probably probably spending
more than an hour a day because when you
first start is very tough it's tired
it's frustrating you're forgetting
everything and so you less fun so it's
hard to get in that our day but now that
I can understand so much more in fact
I'm doing more than an hour a day
because I'm downloading stuff from the
internet reading listening and and
having more fun with it
but an hour a day but if you are a
full-time student you can be doing six
seven hours a day and I have always felt
that if the the more you do a day that
you will learn a lot faster like if you
can do five six hours a day the
intensity of that learning experience
means that you will learn faster than if
you string it out over three years like
I learned Chinese up to with a level of
the British foreign service exam in
about nine to ten months but I was
studying six seven hours a day so the
more intensive your interaction with the
language the more intensively you spend
that time with the language the quicker
you're going to learn the other thing
about it people have said well how long
will it take
don't be so hung up about how long it
will take
try to make sure you enjoy doing it that
should be the goal because if you enjoy
doing it you'll end up spending enough
time and you will learn as quickly as
you can learn so the key is to find
activities that you enjoy doing
now some reservations I think there are
some activities that are very enjoyable
that are probably at least in my opinion
less efficient I think reading and
listening is more efficient than
watching videos or movies because you
are totally dependent on the words
whereas with the videos and the movies
first of all the dialogue is less dense
there's a lot more action and second of
all you're getting a lot of hints let's
not say you shouldn't watch movies but
make sure you get a balance I think if
you were to spend the next two years
doing nothing but watching you know
television in the language you're trying
to learn you wouldn't get as far as if
you you know had the discipline to do a
lot more listening and reading
um yeah I had a few notes so yeah just
to finalize of course the amount of time
that you're going to be able to spend or
are willing to spend is going to be
influenced by
your attitude so the three elements
attitude time and the ability to notice
are all interconnected and we'll see
that too and I discuss noticing but if
you like the language you know if an
immigrant is not happy to be say in
Canada they wishes they were back
somewhere else they really don't want to
mingle with english-speaking people they
somehow feel that they should learn the
language just in case they get stopped
by the police or end up in a hospital
you know those people are not gonna put
in the time if they're very motivated
they're thrilled to be here like I was
thrilled to be in Japan I was thrilled
to study Chinese I was thrilled to be in
France so I was very motivated because I
was happy to be there I wanted to
connect with the locals so the more
motive whatever your motivation is it
could be an interest in the culture in
the literature a spouse a friend
music you know anime in the case of
Japanese if you're motivated you're
gonna spend the time so there's a real
connection between how motivated you are
the attitude your ability to enjoy it
and the amount of time you spend so
there you have it you have to spend the
time and you have to find ways to make
that time enjoyable and effective and
don't worry too much about how long it
takes but make sure that you do things
that you enjoy and that you find are
effective and that can vary from person
to person so thank you for listening bye
for now